we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p there is a caller known to
us as the kansas troll this is a guy who
actually called in to sam cedars show
with horribly racist stuff i think the
video on sam cedars channel is something
like incredibly stupid young man tries
to argue with sam about the bell curve
or something like that he's called in to
us before he's actually called in live
and he face-planted with something about
Alex Jones and me selling supplements he
will often call in and attack me for my
position on a story I never covered and
that's exactly what he's doing today
he's resurfaced and he is attacking me
for my terrible coverage of some
Hispanic girl that was crying I don't
even know what he's talking about but
certainly not a story that I covered
take a listen to this blah blah do you
ever shut up back minute anyways you
know you're talking about this little uh
this little illegal immigrant girl
crying you know boo who McDavid nobody
cares like you know they can just take
packing just like you did you can go
straight back to Argentina I mean you
can go back to Europe you know
originally where are you even from David
right no no even know where you're from
you know anyways you know this little
Mexican and legalistic canonical works
you can go look for some trabajo you
know go Samia huevos that Kip hustles
Cici looking for work yes I can help her
if you want you know get in contact it's
a little illegal girl and I won't get
her a job right thanks dude yep never
covered the story don't know what you're
talking about and it's weird a lot of
the trolls regularly callin to criticize
me for my view on stories I've just not
talked about there's this other guy the
San Antonio troll people wonder why when
I see to10 pop up during live calls I
say San Antonio is a problematic area
code for us it's because of the san
antonio troll who also calls in with
just devastating takedowns of me for
stories i've not even covered really
weird try calling and talking to me
about something i've actually discussed
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about walmart banning
violent imagery but
something else that they should probably
ban if they want to deal with violence
will also talk about the most overworked
cities in the United States the list
might surprise you and lastly the space
force is closer to launching and we will
talk about that all on today's bonus
show get instant access by becoming a
member or a patron I'll talk to you then